I already told you that Donald Trump was extremely
triggered this weekend and absolutely lost
it on Twitter, tweeting 52 times in an hour,
tweeting one hundred and twenty five times
on Sunday.
I mean, just absolutely outrageous, unhinged
conspiracy tweets and what I like to call
agit trash.
It appears that one of the triggering events
for Donald Trump this weekend was former President
Barack Obama accurately criticizing Donald
Trump for his failed essentially fake corona
virus response, which has not even really
been a response, which I think justifies calling
it fake.
The phrase that Barack Obama used for Trump's
handling of Corona virus was, quote, an absolute
chaotic disaster.
Let's check it out from the Obama call with
supporters where he said this has been an
absolute chaotic disaster when that mindset.
What's in it for me?
And to heck with everybody else with that
mindset is operationalized.
An hour ago, I would actually go further.
Barack Obama says that the Trump mindset of
what's in it for me has been operationalised
by our government in terms of Corona virus.
It has been I don't want to overuse the term,
but, you know, it applies here.
Trump's guiding principle of what's in it
for me and what's in it for my reelection.
It has been weaponized by this administration
and it has killed many people who did not
need to die.
Now, the reactions from Trump and Trump ists
have been completely predictable.
First of all, they're doing this entire.
Oh, you know, this is this is the coarsening
of the discourse.
Presidents shouldn't criticize their successors,
rather let meddle.
This is a red herring because notice that
they don't say presidents shouldn't criticize
other presidents because Trump regularly slams
Obama put pulls Obama into insane conspiracy
theories.
A Trump slams Bush, Trump slams Clinton.
So understand the flaccid hypocrisy of this.
A former president shouldn't criticize the
current president.
But Trump regularly bashing former presidents
is fine.
They are predictably pathetic and so pathetically
predictable.
Number two, the right is reviving O'Bama conspiracies
as a result of this.
So be on the lookout for those.
Not only are they saying now that Barack Obama
was personally and illegally involved in trying
to destroy Trump's presidency before it even
got started.
Michael Flynn, you know, all this other stuff,
pizza.
I mean, it's just it's crazy what Obama is
being pulled into.
That's number one.
But number two, they're again, starting to
try to rehabilitate things from the Obama
era.
Like, for example, H1, N1 and Ebola.
H1N1 is a different story altogether.
It didn't have the political implications
of Ebola.
But remember that with Ebola in 2014,
there were two people who died in the United
States.
There were two cases that were transmitted
in the United States.
There were four cases.
These are four, not 4000, not 40000, but four
million.
Four cases were first diagnosed in the United
States.
Eleven cases total and two deaths.
Trump himself was calling for Obama's removal
in 2014, and we knew it was all politics.
Do you remember how we knew that the 2014
Ebola outbreak was all politics to attack
Obama?
Well, because the day after the 2014 midterm
election, we essentially never heard about
Ebola again leading up to it.
You had I remember Rand Paul was unhinged.
Obama had failing on Ebola.
We had two deaths.
Doesn't make them not tragic, but we had two
deaths.
We are at 80, 1000 deaths.
And Trump is making.
The argument that the cupboards were bare
from the Obama
administration that it's China's fault.
Any shortages of PPE are because of governors.
Everybody's fault other than his own.
When he said when you're president, the buck
stops with you, when it was Barack Obama there
at that again.
OK.
Talking about Ebola and then we get to our
third issue.
Just look at how painfully unstable Donald
Trump is.
I was thinking of how to say it in other terms,
but Trump has had months to deal with this.
Obama accurately says it's been a chaotic
disaster and this sets Trump off on it.
Was it 24, 36, 48 hours of hundreds of tweets
attacking Obama, acting like the exact chaotic
mess that Barack Obama describes?
While the cases continue to pile up and the
deaths continue to pile up, I was thinking
last night about an email I received.
Someone wrote to me and said essentially,
listen, Trump's
basically doing as well, handling the virus
as any random person off of the street would
do, kind of making the argument that, like,
listen, Trump's handling it poorly, but it's
roughly what would happen if we voted in any
random person and said deal with Corona virus.
I completely disagree.
Trump is doing worse than the average person.
Trump has very acute personality issues that
make him extra poorly suited at dealing with
this.
Trump believes he knows more than everybody
else.
Trump focuses on attacking others and shifting
blame instead of fixing problems.
My contention to you is if you took a random
person off the street, they'd probably do
better than Trump because they wouldn't bring
the delusions of grandeur, they wouldn't bring
the narcissism.
And so they would say, hey, let's find some
experts and let the experts do their thing
and we would all be
better off.
I believe Donald Trump is actually doing a
markedly worse job than a random person off
of the street would do.
If you said, what about a random doctor?
They would absolutely handle it better than
Donald Trump has.
In total, the average person is likely to
have better handled coronavirus than did Donald
Trump.
I'm glad that Barack Obama spoke up.
You know, right away you have the people who
are saying, oh, now we're we're normalizing
Barack Obama's presidency with the drones.
No, we're not.
We're just saying.
Obama recognizes what's going on.
And he said it.
And it's important for him to say it.
And I'm glad that he did.
That's all that we are saying.